the world has this week been marking the
75th anniversary of the liberation of
the Auschwitz death camp in 1945
survivors gave painful testimony of the
horror they experienced during the
Holocaust in nazi-occupied Poland it's a
warning to today's world we're in
Germany and elsewhere hatred and
anti-semitism are on the rise so our
question on to the point is remembering
l sh wits could it happen again
[Music]
well thanks very much indeed for joining
me here on to the point where my guests
in the studio are root for the
representative here in Germany of the
Yad Vashem Holocaust Remembrance Center
who says the only safeguard against the
evils of Auschwitz is for individuals of
all backgrounds to remember the power of
complicity also with us is Albert
steinberger a Deutsche Welle video maker
and producer with both Brazilian and
German roots he's done a lot of work
exploring anti-semitism and argues that
yes it could happen again this huge
concern he says about the rise of
extremism anti-semitism and hatred and
the warm welcome to to Matthias Heil the
head of educational services at the
ravensbrück concentration camp in the
moral site who says quite plainly know
the history or face the consequences
thank you all three for being with me
here today on the show I'd like to begin
with you route in recent days ceremonies
speeches and gatherings very painful
testimony from the survivors where have
your thoughts taking you in the last
couple of days
well absolutely it's been a very intense
week with events happening in Jerusalem
in Auschwitz and here as well as all
over the world I spent a few days in
Jerusalem at Yad Vashem at the ceremony
at the fifth world Holocaust forum that
took place for the first time in
Jerusalem over 45 world leaders
presidents prime ministers Heads of
Government Kings attended and it was a
very sobering event there was a large
contingency of survivors in the room and
it was a huge demonstration of the
standing together against anti-semitism
and bringing all those people together
is a testimony to how important the
subject is today and it's very important
for very many different reasons but one
of them is this that many of the
survivors a large contingent you talks
about elder
people that sir they they view
themselves as a finite group how
important is that absolutely crucial the
difference between reading a book and
sitting opposite a person who's
experienced these things themselves who
has emerged from the darkest chapter of
human history is incomparable
we opened last week an exhibition of 75
portraits of survivors in Essen at the
ticket sold fine
the photographs are hung at eye level
and when you look these people in the
face and see the marks of history on
their faces and read the short
description of what they went through
it's a totally different experience from
as I said simply reading the books or
watching a film
sure but here's how you work at the
former concentration camp in Ravens
Brook which is about sort of 90
kilometers I think north of where we are
here in the German capital if I'm right
Lee informed it was a camp that was
exclusively for women and I'd like you
to tell us what work you do today what
is the aim of the work you do at the
camp today for us it's quite important
to let people gain knowledge about what
happened there so that they will be able
to find some links to the presence and
for me it's a privilege that I had a
chance and my colleagues from a team had
a chance to meet a lot of survivors and
for it was a former women's
concentration camp we still have these
vital 80 to 90 years old ladies coming
over some of them promised to themselves
they would never ever would like to
enter Germany anymore but they came back
and for me it's quite nice to see that
we will have our 75th anniversary of
liberation in April and we are preparing
a program where we hope that a lot of
survivors would come again I'm second
generation third generation so this is a
place of encounters where the survivors
and their stories have their places and
it's a place where it's important to
confirm
the German society and others with
bystanders issues with the stories of
the perpetrators when you talk about
confronting German society your your
mantra your your watchword we just heard
it at the top of the show is know the
history or face the consequences to
people in Germany today know the history
do they care I think a lot of people
know some people know and they don't
care and there are some people who know
a lot but they have their different
ideas about their part of the past they
are pro-nazi a lot of Nazis know a lot
about what happened and they find it ok
what happens and they come to you they
come to your memorial sent and they
express these views and you are
confronted with these views usually we
are not confronted with it takes some
time to find out about Nazi ideas among
students for instance because usually
the students know from the teachers what
they are expected to show up with in the
former concentration camp so I can't see
mirrored the current political shifts we
have in our society and the wizardess
group mm-hmm
Albert Steinberg are a lot of the work
you have done in recent times has been
focused on the Holocaust and the scourge
of anti-semitism why is it so important
to you well I think exactly what what
the Koch was saying about looking at the
present and we have nowadays a rise of
extreme right and a rise of
anti-semitism and this is quite
concerning and I think it was a minimum
Akram who in one of the festivities said
one of the celebration said that it's
not about only it's not a problem that's
about the Jewish communities about all
of us because we lose the the the human
value when we go through these things
and that's the point and that's why we
we were looking at the events also in
trying to to put it like in in the
context of today of anti-semitism an you
have anti-semitism growing not only in
Germany but you have also in Brooklyn
people being attacked on the streets in
Paris so we did a big documentary
exactly getting all these angles that's
actually at the moment of worldwide
so I'm a little bit more about the
alternative for Germany the political
party here in Germany the far-right
populist party that is now the strongest
opposition party in the German
parliament they talk about and I'm
quoting here drawing a line under German
history closing the chapter moving on
they say we should not wallow in guilt
as they put it what's your response to
all that I think they go even further
because what they're doing is trying to
tell a new narrative about it when they
say that they could as the French and as
the British they should be proud of
their troops in the Second World War
they are trying to tell another story
and that's very dangerous for society
and it's very dangerous as well because
I think you always will have people that
are a minority but there are extremes in
there are neo-nazis I mean in every
society you have that the problems that
that when that goes mainstream what that
goes to the Parliament and that's what's
I think the biggest issue in the German
society nowadays root
what is your response to the AFD his
quarter of the world's going to that
part in some parts of Germany it's a
problem for us and sometimes when I read
the sources from the late period of the
Weimar Republic I feel that there are
some things in the strategies of the AFD
and other right-wing organizations which
really make me fear about the future
because you can read it in the sources
from the 1920's 1930's how people
develop a strategy and opening the room
the space for bringing in anti-semitic
and other ideas and then you can see how
this democracy a very young and weak
democracy in the nineteen twenties 30s
failed and this should be a point for us
to learn about the steps right wing
strategies go step by step to a
direction which makes a society failure
I absolutely agree
I think that looking at the origins of
the Holocaust is a key aspect that has
to be it has to be learnt has to be
society needs to be aware of how
discrimination anti-semitism all forms
of xenophobia can have disastrous
consequences and this is obviously has
become a huge part of the work of
adverse xem which was initially more
focused on the Holocaust and telling
massing as much information what I call
turning every stone finding information
about every individual who was lost and
now a lot more work is being done about
anti-semitism trying to understand the
origins of what happened and I think
that our collective responsibility of
course is to keep aware of these things
and and and use the Holocaust as a
narrative of how things can go so
terribly wrong in society okay before we
talk about the the scourge and the roots
of anti-semitism let's listen to what
some of the survivors of Auschwitz have
been saying in recent days
my number is seventy five thousand three
hundred and five which I had to shout
twice daily at counting sale a pill he
had to shout our number there on gypsy
2,300 films I can't even think about it
why why a nine-year-old girl who hadn't
done anything who hadn't sinned why did
they murder her why many more sometimes
when I'm asleep I still dream about it
and I scream even though I'm 86 years
old now the air was full of ash like
snow from there from the smoke from the
chimneys this was a ashes from from
Tacoma Toria
and we just had to understand that this
is what happens there routes I've got to
come back to you the in that testimony
there's so many questions so much
bewilderment the nightmares of this of
the survivors despite all that the
personal and the political now you as
far as I understand it a year ago
decided to become a German to apply for
German citizenship and you have become a
German some would ask how could you take
that step and join this country join
these people who have such a shameful
past yeah well I feel actually very
proud to be German I've yes I think it
is and I think that Germany has a lot to
be proud of I first of all it's very
interesting for me as a Jew to now be
now to also be German to have this part
of my identity and to be dealing with
the Holocaust and these issues sort of
from the other side or from within in a
way and I feel myself as a sort of new
immigrant to the country you're a
straight holder I'm a stake holder
exactly so I can sort of see it from
both perspectives in a way I mean I have
to say that when I heard president
Steinmeier speaking at Yad Vashem
and also at the Bundestag yesterday I I
I felt that my pride was well-founded I
felt that he spoke in a way that that
reflected the kinds of values that I
would want this country to espouse
values that I could relate to and it was
done with dignity with solemnity and
with in wholehearted commitment to
understanding the past and a commitment
to the survivors to us and to future
generations that this is a subject that
will remain a top priority despite all
of what you are saying anti-semitism in
Germany is still on the rise this is the
country of the Holocaust this is the
country of that testimony that we just
heard how does that fit together
well there that's a good question but I
believe that one of the key points here
is the Internet and the extreme right
groups they control a big chunk of the
Internet at the moment and that's
extremely dangerous so how we address to
the new generations how we tell the
stories of these old survivors to the
new generation because if you look at
like the strategy the internet and
Twitter is the new radio of the Nazis
they can reach straight they don't need
journalists like us they can go straight
and speak their mind out and they go
unpunished when they when they spread
and semitic ideas or racist ideas so
that is one of the key issues that i
think we're we're missing sometimes when
we discuss this and and you have like
the rise of the extreme right in several
countries internet is always key social
media is always key mm-hmm you have the
rise of the far right here in germany
you have the rise of anti-semitism at
the same time the the jewish community
here in germany is getting is getting
bigger Angela Merkel talks of that as a
sort of a miracle is that how you see it
I think there is one historical fact
that most of the perpetrators never were
put to trial so the German society for a
long time managed to avoid any
confrontation with a past and especially
the Nazis never were brought to trial
and in a society where over generations
there is a narrative that the Nazis came
into the country in 1933 and they
somehow we're away from 1945 on and this
was a country without the former Nazis
this narrative was very strong up to the
1980s and since then and especially
since the 1990s we have stronger
memorial sites a lot of memorial sites
in West Germany were the product of the
fight of people the struggle of people
fighting against the establishment to
establish kind of new culture of memory
so we always have these both sides
people trying to avoid
any confrontation we have there's who
tried to bring a wise to the resistance
to the Jewish voices but it was a
struggle all over the years and now
anti-semitism gets stronger Internet as
part of it it's easier to spread these
messages but on the other hand it was
always here for me it's a miracle that
we are in a situation that the
government the politicians are agreeing
to saying that it is constitutional for
the German society that Israel's there
but more Jews getting afraid to live
here in what kind of society are we
living and this is what asked us to act
let's go to some images then
illustrating the extent to which members
of the Jewish community here in Germany
do feel ambivalent about the future
Jewish communications designer Valentin
Lutz it has been calling Berlin home for
eight years he actually feels pretty
comfortable living in Germany it's a
very diverse community it's just very
pleasant here this has become a Jewish
quarter again but on October 9th this
image is shattered Valentin goes to the
synagogue in Halle to mark Yom Kippur
the Day of Atonement a right-wing
terrorist attacks the synagogue after he
fails to penetrate the door he shoots
two people on the street the attacker
had announced his anti-semitic views on
the internet using a helmet camera he
broadcast the attack on a streaming
platform Valentin Lucette is deeply
shocked as a consequence of everyday
anti-semitism he very rarely wears his
kippa in public anymore
Kisuke Lord honest I try not to provoke
people
it's Eden there are situations where I
don't need to be clearly identifiable as
Jewish should out still and most is
Germany habitable for Jews
well that's the big overarching question
but I root with the question I would
like to ask is and he goes in the same
direction is how great is your sense and
the sense perhaps in the Jewish
community that there was a before
challah and an after challah
well obviously Hollow was a wake up call
no one imagined that entrust of that
scale could take place obviously Jewish
institutions school synagogues etc are
protected the fact that challah was so
unprotected was a shop in its own right
I happen to be in my own synagogue at
that time when the news came out of what
happened in challah it's a huge shock
it's particularly shocking that it
happened in Germany
I mean we've we've seen a spate of
attacks all over the world we somehow
think that in Germany things are
different it's shocking that it's gotten
worse it could be much worse -
bystanders were killed because they
happen to be in the vicinity but if the
if the gunman had got into the synagogue
dozens of people could have been
massacred it could have been much worse
I agree and it's it's it's an extremely
frightening development and that's why
our leaders and I speak about our
leaders here in Germany and across the
world we have to take and they have
taken much stronger stand legally
against such situations I'd like to go
back to the educationalist
you know in our around how much
understanding perhaps do you have for
people who say I'm too young it's not my
problem it's ancient history how much
understanding do you have for people who
say you know I am from a Germany is a
country of great diversity I am from a
different community not from the
mainline German community it's not my
problem I think if you start telling the
story of confronting people in a way
that they feel that you are full of
respect towards them it's easier for
them to accept that it is needed
knowledge if you don't have it under
your eyes you have it in your neck and
the German situation you need to know
about the past and order
to be able to participate in the
discourse and I feel that some of their
students complaining about it too much
these are those who know the little the
the least and this who know more they
usually don't complain about it too much
there is some resistance among young
people where they learn from their
parents that it should not be touched
but if you as a society as an
educational system are willing to give
the stories to the young people in a way
that it is not too overwhelming to them
then you can open doors if you want to
answer all questions at once in two and
a half hours of visiting a memorial site
like this then you will close the doors
definitely yeah there's been a lot of
talk about people saying one of the main
solutions to dealing with anti-semitism
is to get the young people to go to
places like your commemoration site but
they have to be prepared they have to
have the right mindset they have to they
have to be open to the experience before
they arrive otherwise it will possibly
backfire and we can't create a miracle
within two and a half hours we can't
change anti-semitic person into a good
Liberal Democrat in this time by
confronting them and some teachers they
want us to develop empathy on the
students but very often the students
don't feel that they are dealt with in
empathy at school so it's too much asked
from a memorial site to start with
gaining some or developing some empathy
if they are not used to it at school but
you said at the top of the show you were
quite forthright you said yes it can
happen again that is after all our
question remembering our shoe it's can
it be repeated why do you think so
strongly that it can happen again well
if you look at history and you see how
democracy can
sometimes can swing to the right to the
left and and that's why when when apart
from the extreme right like if they go
mainstream you can have you have already
some people from the right party of of
Germany discussing possible alliances
with IFA for example so this is the sort
of thought it's extremely dangerous
because then you can have a party inside
the department that you wouldn't have an
idea what it could go through and what
what kind of journey could take us
through mm-hmm could it happen again I
believe not but you believe not I
believe not but talking about Germany
now that you were that you were praising
for its efforts to come to wrestle with
history well I believe it's our
collective responsibility to fight
against it I've heard I'm mortified to
hear survivors saying that they believe
it can happen again people who
experienced numerous yeah it must
strengthen our resolve to do everything
we can to fight against anti-semitism
and xenophobia in all forms and it is
not the responsibility of the Jewish
community it is not it is a collective
responsibility that every single citizen
needs to have had it happen again in the
hand
Woody Allen's movie Hannah and her
sisters there is one quote way says it's
the wrong question how could it happen
we should ask why didn't it happen more
often and I think the risk of repetition
is always there we are human beings they
were human beings so history doesn't
repeat the same way but the risks in
mankind are the same and it was ordinary
Germans talking about this idea of evil
buts it's somehow in the human psyche
it's not only evil it's human beings and
their potentials and evil as part of it
root the last word well my last word is
that education is the only way of
fighting that evil I agree that
education that I think also like we need
also to have a stronger measurement
center
of security of police and and also
tackling the issue of internet and and
and and have these ideas spread because
of course you have the ideas already on
the ground but they are spreading
they're growing in that's dangerous and
educators are novices or wizards
unfortunately unfortunately okay thanks
very much for joining us here on to the
point today we've been talking about
remembering Auschwitz can it happen
again I hope we've given you plenty of
food for thoughts and if we have to come
back next week until then bye-bye and
choice
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]